[Musica]
quanto più giovane è una cultura tanto
più grande il suo timore dinanzi al
calar della notte
questa cosa non l'ho scritta io l'ho
letta sul libro che ho comprato
tantissimi anni fa
girovagando tra delle bancarelle quando
appunto la curiosità di provare cose
nuove
era appunto andando nelle bancarelle
guardandosi intorno
non c'era ancora il web non c'era ancora
internet e quindi avevo trovato questo
libro è un titolo che aveva subito
attirato la mia attenzione che hera luce
storia della luce artificiale nel xix
secolo e quindi dentro questo libro ho
trovato questa frase che ho trovato
subito interessante perché
effettivamente pensando a quelli che
dovevano essere i nostri antenati 1000
2000 5000 anni fa 10.000 anni fa mi
segnato a pensare cosa accadeva quando
andava via
quando andava via la luce alla luce
naturale quindi dopo il tramonto quelle
che dovevano essere le loro paure perché
si ritrovavano un certo punto senza più
luce e senza mezzi per illuminare e e
quindi ad esempio quando poi ri
albeggiava c'era questo il sole che
diventava un dio così come c'era la luna
così come c'erano
c'era la nebbia che gli affascinava e
quindi questa cosa nel già da ragazzino
insomma mi era una cosa che mi
affascinava e anche i miei primi ricordi
proprio i miei primi ricordi quando ero
veramente piccolo ero insomma ero ancora
i miei genitori sono comunque legati
alla luce ad esempio ricordo questo
viaggio che facevamo tutte le estati
andavamo da pescara che la mia città a
trento che la città di mia mamma quindi
i nostri genitori ci facevano partire
nel mio fratello
la notte così intanto dormivamo in
macchina avevamo questa vecchia auto
bianchi si portavano quindi da pescara a
trento e è un certo punto quando
dormivamo mi ricordo sempre che mia
mamma sul durante il percorso
sull'autostrada quando iniziava ad
albeggiare il sole mia mamma mi
svegliava medicea michele guardì guarda
il sole eravamo ancora appunto
sull'adriatica quindi sedeva il sole che
sorgeva dal mare io vedevo questa questa
palla infuocata e quindi nero nero
affascinato e probabilmente è un po
simile appunto quello che accadeva ai
nostri antenati migliaia di anni prima
anche perché è quello che accade anche
tuttora a un bambino perché chiaramente
un bimbo di solito non vede l'alba no
perché sta dormendo a quell'ora è la
stessa cosa che succederà in un modo
diverso anche il ritorno perché invece
il viaggio di ritorno da trento pescara
di solito era lo facciamo il pomeriggio
la sera e quindi da un certo punto mi
trovavo ma l'altezza e la pianura padana
e vedevo tutto appunto questa nebbia
questa luce un po fredda e poi non so in
lontananza c'era un casolare con una
lucina calda accesa e quindi anche
questa cosa mi affascinava capito che
c'era qualcosa anche questa immagine
della nebbia che poteva essere un po
angosciante mi creava però un'atmosfera
capito che c'era qualcosa dietro e
e questa cosa che insomma ha creato in
me tanto interesse e tanta passione
fortunatamente devo dire è diventata il
mio lavoro faccio il direttore della
fotografia e appunto e o e ho la fortuna
di lavorare con tanti film con tanti
registi e poter dare il mio servizio a
dei film ad esempio dei film per
raccontarvi un po di me anche se poi è
stato detto del film che ho fatto di
quelli appunto che mi sono rimasti di
più uno di questi è lo chiamavano jeeg
robot che comunque è stato un film
appunto interessante da realizzare così
come veloce come il vento che un film
che a che fare anche con oltre che con
appunto una certa fotografia anche con
delle scene d'azione insomma un'altra
cosa punto che così di cui volevo
parlare brevemente giusto per
raccontarvi di me e ad esempio ho fatto
tre puntate della prima serie di gomorra
che anche questo è un altro mondo
interessante che abbiamo raccontato così
come appunto lavorare con registi più
grandi come martone moretti e anche
questa insomma è alla fine insomma è una
cosa che mi riempie di orgoglio e penso
anche di essere fortunato a poter poter
lavorare con questi registi e e quindi
appunto però molti mi chiedono ma cosa
fa esattamente un direttore della
fotografia effettivamente magari molti è
un nome che ormai si sente spesso però
non si capisce o non tutti sanno quello
che faccio esattamente vi faccio degli
esempi pratici banali ad esempio
prendiamo una scena al ristorante una
scena al ristorante
girata al ristorante uno pensa c'è il
ristorante ci sono le luci del
ristorante arrivi e giri invece non è
così nel senso che diciamo che la ogni
scena per essere per essere raccontata
per essere inquadrata chiaramente ha
bisogno di essere illuminata ma
l'illuminazione colui che la controlla è
il direttore della fotografia quindi
qualsiasi scena anche la scena del
ristorante ha bisogno di luci che
possono non essere quella del ristorante
c'è possiamo oltre luci del ristorante
aggiungere delle luci che lo spettatore
non vede ma che creano l'atmosfera delle
luci che sono proprio delle luci del
cinema o addirittura possiamo spegnere
le luci del ristorante aggiungerne delle
altre noi che non si vedono che si
vedono possiamo far filtrare delle luci
dalle dalle finestre per ricreare la
luce del sole possiamo fare entrare
veramente la luce del sole possiamo
ricreare con dei proiettori da luce del
sole
questo è in pratica il lavoro del
direttore alla fotografia che quindi più
che far vedere una scena la deve far
sentire far sentire come emozione
proprio per raccontare quello che c'è
nel nella sceneggiatura perché
effettivamente quello che poi mi accade
quotidianamente che a me come a tutti i
miei colleghi che arriva un copione una
sceneggiatura dove c'è scritto dove c'è
tutto il film e la manda o il regista
che vuole lavorare con me o piuttosto
che il produttore quale vuole affidare
un bel film e quindi da questa
sceneggiatura per questo copione inizio
a farmi delle idee che atmosfere create
ne parlo col regista e ne parlò che
questo è l'altro aspetto direttore alla
fotografia ne parlo anche con la
produzione perché ogni film costa molto
tutto il materiale che usiamo è un
materiale molto costoso servono tante
persone per farlo e quindi ogni giornata
di un film ha un costo importante e per
questo tutte le nostre scelte o tre
rullato artistico hanno anche un lato
pratico che discutiamo proprio con con
la produzione con quelli che mettono e
gestiscono i soldi quindi
fondamentalmente
queste cose vanno di pari passo poi si
fanno appunto quelli che sono i
sopralluoghi dove si va nello specifico
da analizzare come girare ogni singola
scena e poi si arriva magicamente
proprio sul set dove iniziamo ogni
giorno a a girare varie scene bisogna
sapere che sul set oltre a continuare
con questa ricerca artistica e visiva
c'è qui entra ancora più un gioco quella
che è la pratica quella che è la pratica
della singola giornata perché dovete
sapere che a un certo punto della
giornata per ogni inquadratura che
facciamo
c'è un signore che si chiama che di
solito l'aiuto regista che viene da me
che viene dal direttore alla fotografia
e mi chiede sei pronto fin quando il
direttore della fotografia non è pronto
non si può girare ma questo per ogni
inquadratura per ogni giorno e per ogni
set che uno gira aspettano il direttore
fotografia quindi questa è una cosa che
chiaramente mi fa onore e piacere a
tutti quelli che fanno il direttore
fotografia però anche una cosa che sa
che è una responsabilità importante
perché chiaramente più il film è grande
più una singola giornata costa parecchio
più ci sono dei ritardi e e più sale
l'ansia quindi diciamo che la cosa per
cui poi mia mi affascina il mio lavoro e
se appunto per questa ricerca visiva per
questo guardarsi intorno eccetera ma
anche poi per un lato pratico perché
effettivamente dobbiamo cioè appunto sul
7 arriva l'aiuto regia e rompe tra
virgolette questa questa magia questo
essere diciamo solo artisti e quindi lei
intendo ad esempio la fotografia non
solo come molti non so scrivono luce
gaulle l maiuscola scrivono filosofia
della luce con un appunto con questi
paroloni ma nintendo come un lavoro
fatto sicuramente di talento talento che
non mi riconosco io ma mi riconoscono le
persone che mi chiamano è fatto però
appunto di di una grande praticità di un
artigianalità che proprio tipica anche
del nostro modo di fare cinema in italia
e che è stato esportato anche all'estero
mi ricordo ad esempio stavo facendo
veloce come il vento punto il film tra
l'altro che il quale ho vinto il david
di donatello alla fotografia e ci
trovavamo in basilicata a girare delle
scene di questa gara clandestina ed ero
proprio in macchina stiamo girando dal
pero c'era stefano accorsi che tra
l'altro un gran pilota che guidava
veramente lui questa peugeot 205 turbo
16 una vecchia gloria del rally eravamo
io e lui da soli è un certo punto perché
stavamo girando dal vero quindi la
troupe era era distante eravamo solo io
e lui io ero nell'abitacolo a fianco a
lui anche perché essendo piccolino
entravo proprio perfettamente nel un
certo punto la macchina si blocca e
arriva questo questo consegnatario della
peugeot che era un signore francese e
prende uno stecchino per terra che
probabilmente era un gelato ore insomma
è uno stecchino di un gelato poi con del
nastro che avevamo messo sopra una
macchina da presa l'ha preso la messo
dentro il motore e siamo ripartiti
questo è un po l'artigianalità secondo
me che c'è un po nel cinema e che
secondo me ci deve essere anche nel
appunto nella luce nel modo di
rappresentare la luce tanto è vero che
poi noi siamo ripartiti con questa
questa macchina sono ripartiti siamo
rimasti di nuovo da sole da soli sentito
proprio il rumore di questo motore
antico che spingeva molto forte e nel
frattempo appunto eravamo io stefano
accorsi
il rumore di questa macchina e questi
tramonti della basilicata e cavi ho
detto che ho pensato mi sento fortunato
che riesco a raccontare questa cosa
anche con la luce naturale anche
osservando quello che c'è intorno
anche se poi questo film sarà un film
dove ci saranno gli effetti perché
magari cancelleremo qualcosa avremmo
prof
c'è qualcosa di vero di naturale che
stiamo raccontando e
osservare osservare le cose osservare la
luce per quello che è e non per
l'effetto che ha è una cosa che comunque
consiglio a chi è appassionato di luce a
chi magari ambisce a fare questo lavoro
comunque ambisce a fare cinema o
comunque ambisce a raccontare per
immagini
la cosa che volevo lasciare come come me
nella mia idea di luce soprattutto
appunto chi magari ha in mente di fare
questa cosa qui e soprattutto di
osservarsi di guardarsi intorno ad
esempio me questa cosa ormai mi viene
naturale io in ogni ambiente dove mi
trovo che sia bellissimo o anche
squallido mi viene da vedere come
illuminato ma in un modo cioè che non
ormai non è una deformazione
professionale cioè lo so anche la mia
fidanzata sa che noi quando parliamo io
però sto sempre vedendo come illuminata
civile naturale cioè se vedo che c'è una
luce strana dico aspetta un attimo fammi
vedere ma com'è da dove arriva questa
luce c'è anche adesso sai vedo queste
questo proiettore che ciò con le luci
che sono dietro si arriverebbe da
cambiare dal sistema e perché dico
questo perché sicuramente ci vuole una
passione e soprattutto ai ragazzi
cercate comunque di di creare delle
immagini che siano stati che quindi
fotografie che siano i movimenti che
però siano delle immagini che abbiano
del significato c'è adesso con instagram
coi social con tutto quello che è spesso
vedo delle immagini che non sono
immagini ma che sono effetti c'è ovvero
dove l'effetto va oltre l'immagine dove
l'immagine in realtà è solo un filtro
cioè nel senso non viene l'immagine non
ha significato ma significato l'effetto
quindi viene cioè non cerchiamo immagini
ma cerchiamo di creare gli effetti per
cui la nostra foto diventa può diventare
un bottino da esibire
invece non è quello ma proprio dobbiamo
capire la naturalezza della luce per poi
magari trasformarla fatte sempre quando
sono arrivato ho visto che si sono
passate queste tende detto peccato
chiaramente è comodo averle chiusa per
vederci meglio c'è
però per dire cerchiamo anche la
naturalezza e non cerchiamo di avere
solo solo degli effetti perché poi alla
fine non
non arriveremo da nessuna parte perché
poi appunto il cinema è l'immagine
comunque e semplicità e naturalezza
grazie
[Applauso]